[Music]
on this episode of travel care I'm
taking Joe on a clear kayak adventure
through the Florida Keys and I'm taking
Caroline to Sunsail water sport we're
gonna Paris Dale swear your feet in the
air come join us on our adventures on
this episode of travel chairs
welcome to travel tears I'm Joe and I'm
Caroline today we are in key what Key
West is the perfect vacation getaway
from its relaxing beaches - it's
gorgeous natural habitat well are you
ready to get started
I'm so stoked here's your clue alright
you're about to see it all okay have to
see it alright bring Key West there's
beautiful stuff everywhere I'm sure I'm
going to see something interesting and
I'm so excited
Joe's a big thrill seeker in a lot of
ways but he's never explored the ocean
like this before
turn turn okay stay there okay don't
take off your blindfold we're exploring
Key West in a clear bottom
[Music]
so clearly a charge has been around for
nine years we take people out [ __ ] and
two or three times a day we go out to
the Key West National Wildlife Refuge
the clear kayaks are good because you
really feel like you're one with the
water you can see everything underneath
you can see the seagrass you can see all
the sponge gardens and it just makes you
feel much more connected with the ocean
while you're out there having a little
bit of solitude out there just a nice
way to spend your day out on the ocean
it's just great to be out there and have
your own little island your own little
piece of the ocean and in the clear
kayaks you just really feel connected
you feel like there's nothing between
you and the water your heart rate drops
and it's just a real mellow experience
[Music]
Caroline that was awesome and now time
for your clue okay I'm excited time to
rise to the occasion all right I wonder
what that means what no I feel like rise
to the occasion as if build up to
something intense so I have a feeling it
has to do with Heights
we'll see I just know it's gonna be big
after Caroline's impressive performance
in Salt Lake City I want to take her 300
feet in the air so she can get an
amazing view of Key West
oh listen I got the spot here is game
right here okay take off your blindfold
[Applause]
[Music]
so Caroline how are you feeling Joe I
think he was already gorgeous but seeing
it from up there I feel like it's gonna
be unbelievable okay all right it's a
little rocky that is a really big pair
of shoes that can swallow me up now it's
for real the parachute has gone up it is
time it's time
oh my god it's ready the anticipation is
building up any time now
[Music]
I can't blame oh my god when you're
crying I guess the best way to describe
parasailing would be like floating on a
cloud it's completely opposite of a
rollercoaster like you get up there it's
quiet it's peaceful see over the top of
the island and see the the Gulf of
Mexico on the other side of qsr it's
quite amazing oh I can just relax like
this I love being in the ocean and now I
love seeing it from this view ah I just
wanted to stay up here forever and this
is what the birds feel I don't know why
I'm so nervous about this there's
nothing to be nervous about
I know this looks a lot scarier on land
we've been up here it's just feels
really nice and safe yeah Hugh is like
oh my goodness
[Music]
[Music]
you know we've been to the mountains of
Utah the deserts of Santa Fe and now
we're soaking up the Sun and cue us
Keywest it's a beautiful island we got
to see down in the water
and also way above the entire island all
right Caroline what's my rating jo to be
honest I was a little nervous that you
would be intimidated by all the open
water but when we got in the kayaks you
were so enthusiastic about it all and
had so much fun and you steered like a
pro Thanks so for that I'm giving you a
five out of five awesome thank you let
me tell you I'm a little nervous about
my score when I pick parasailing I was a
little apprehensive because I know
you're afraid of heights and you startle
easily but we got up there you were just
having such a great time and cheering
some screaming and overall you were
really good sport about it so for those
reasons I'm gonna give you a four out of
five okay okay I am so glad that you
took me here it's something that I
wouldn't have done on my own and really
took me out of my comfort zone I had a
lot of fun I feel we've seen the best
parts of Key West and I'm so glad we
came here me too
Key West was so much fun and now we're
ready for the Bahamas
[Music]
you